el consejo de defensa duró cuatro horas
y las declaraciones de roncas diez
minutos en las que el primer ministro
anunció las medidas son más bien el
refuerzo de las medidas para luchar
contra el coronavirus en a francia dijo
que se le va a dar prioridad en los
laboratorios para que las personas que
trabajan como personal sanitario que
hayan estado en contacto con un caso
positivo que tengan síntomas de kobe 19
puedan hacerse los test de manera
prioritaria y sobre todo en unos
horarios solamente para ellos también
confirmó que finalmente el aislamiento
será tan solo de siete días sino de
catorce días y que dos mil personas
vendrán a reforzar todo el sistema de
rastreo de casos positivos pidió a los
prefectos de policías locales que sean
los encargados de tomar medidas como por
ejemplo cambiar o modificar los horarios
de apertura de ciertos comercios y
también sobre el uso de mascarilla todo
esto ya a nivel local y pidió también
que para las ciudades de burdeos de
marsella y para la isla de guadalupe los
prefectos de estos lugares le presenten
medidas este
para luchar activamente contra el virus
en estos tres lugares que son zona roja
y por último le pidió a los franceses
sobre todo ser muy responsables con lo
que está ocurriendo para evitar un
confinamiento general